alex can you tell me what your routine  is can you tell me the millionaire  routine the billionaire routine whatever  what i'm going to tell you is going to  blow you away because what everyone  expects is that they add things to what  they're currently doing you look at your  morning and think oh whatever he's doing  i'm going to add that into what i'm  currently doing when the reality is most  of the people who are further ahead of  you are just not doing things that you  are doing and so you need to look at the  things they are not spending time on  that you are wasting your time on and so  that means that not necessarily doing  your cold plunges your orange glasses  and the finger tissues and the  affirmations in the morning and staring  yourself in the mirror and doing your  pump up speech instead drink a cup of  coffee get to work and realize that the  work is the thing that's going to move  forward and sometimes the doing needs to  do